♪.
PETE: ALL EYES TURN TO GEORGIA
AS THE RUNOFF BETWEEN SENATOR
WARNOCK AND HERSCHEL WALKER
COULD DETERMINE WHETHER
VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS BECOMES
THE SENATE TIEBREAKER.
MILLIONS BEING POURED INTO THE
RUNOFF DESPITE A STAGGERING
$262 MILLION ALREADY SPENT ON
THE RACE.
HERE WITH MORE ON WHAT'S DRIVING
GEORGIA TOWARD BEING A BLUE
STATE, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR AND
GEORGIA NATIVE JOEY JONES.
>> I WOULD SAY GEORGIA IS
DRIVING TOWARDS BEING A PURPLE
STATE.
PETE: I READ WHAT WAS IN THE
TELEPROMPTER.
>> OUR LEGISLATURE GOT STRONGER.
THE STATE IS A VERY RED STATE.
STACY ABRAMS LEGACY THE MACHINE
SHE CREATED TO GET THE VOTES
HARVESTING.
IT IS NOT TECHNICALLY VOTE
THE ACT OF GOING BACKDOOR TO
DOOR MAKING PEOPLE SURE YOU GOT
REGISTERED VOTED DURR VOTING
SEASON.
THE MACHINE SHE BUILT
REPUBLICANS ARE STRUGGLING UP
TO.
PETE: TRENDING IN SOME WAYS
TOWARDS A PURPLE STATE.
IS THAT IN PART BECAUSE
DEMOGRAPHICS MOVED IN?
TALK TO ME.
>> THE DONOR DEMOGRAPHICS HAVE
CHANGED.
HOLLYWOOD MOVED INTO GEORGIA, IN
2016 OR 2018, 60% OF AMERICAN
FILM AND TELEVISION WAS FILMED
IN GEORGIA.
TRICOUNTY AREA SOUTH OF ATLANTA,
AREA AROUND THE AIRPORT,
NETFLIX, AMC, ALL THE MARVEL
MOVIES FROM CAPTAIN AMERICA TWO
THROUGH A VEN
"AVENGERS: ENDGAME."
RAFAEL WARNOCK WILL GET MONEY
ALL DAY LONG BECAUSE HOLLYWOOD
IS IN THE MAIL.
PETE: BLUE DOT IN ATLANTA GOTTEN
BIGGER.
>> EXACTLY RIGHT.
THE IRONY THERE, NOT JUST
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT MORE BLUE
VOTERS BUT THERE IS A LOT MORE
RESOURCES FROM OUT-OF-STATE.
PETE: BLUE MONEY.
WHAT IS THE PREDICTION ON THE
RUNOFF?
>> LAST NIGHT'S NEWS CHANGES
THING.
PEOPLE DON'T FEEL THE URGENCY.
I HOPE REPUBLICANS COULD A LESS,
OF 50-50 AND 51-49.
JOE MANCHIN DOESN'T SELL HIS OWN
STATE OUT A LOT OF MONEY DOESN'T
GET SPENT OVER ONE VOTE.
THERE ARE STILL MODERATE
SENATORS TO TALK TO.
PETE: GOOD POINT.
THIS WILL DETERMINE WHETHER
MANCHIN SETS PREROGATIVES
VIS-A-VIS.
>> OR MAYBE MARK KELLY SEES
WRITING ON THE WALL.
A LOT OF SENATE RACES THAT WERE
CLOSE.
WAS I WAS ON THIS NETWORK
"FOX & FRIENDS" FOUR MONTHS AGO,
INTERVIEWING NEWT GINGRICH
ANOTHER GEORGIA HAS THE PULSE.
LOOKS LIKE WE GOT THE HOUSE.
SENATE IS PROBABLY NOT THERE.
THAT WAS THE BEGINNING OF
REPUBLICANS SAYING NO WE'LL GET
THE SENATE.
THIS HAS BEEN A FOUR-MONTH
WINDOW OVER ENTIRE ELECTION
WINDOW, TWO YEARS WE BELIEVED
THE SENATE WAS OURS TO GET.
THAT DIDN'T COME TO FRUITION.
WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT WHAT WE
DID WRONG.
GEORGIA, TALKING VERY RED
LEGISLATURE.
ONE OF THE MOST POPULAR
GOVERNORS IN THE COUNTRY.
RON DESANTIS GETS CREDIT FOR
OPENING UP FLORIDA.
GEORGIA NEVER CLOSED.
GOVERNOR KEMP DONE A LOT OF GOOD
THINGS.
WHAT I HOPE, WRITING ON THE WALL
SHOW IT, SEE GOVERNOR KEMP AND
DONALD TRUMP ON THE SAME STAGE
GO VOTE FOR HERSCHEL WALKER F
THE REPUBLICANS CAN CAPTURE ANY
UNITY IN THE PARTY THEY NEED,
MAYBE GEORGIA IS THE PLACE TO DO
IT.
PETE: IF THAT CAN HAPPEN
POTENTIALLY HERSCHEL WALKER AND
JOEY JONES.
REAL QUICK, ALMOST OUT OF TIME,
VETERANS DAY SERVICE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
>> TO ALL THE VETERANS, DON'T BE
PASSIVE THIS IS LIVE FORCE
LIVING.
WE LOST GUYS AND GALS AND OWE IT
TO THEM LIVE OUR LIFE WELL.
MILITARY BRINGS AND MAKES US A
BETTER PERSON.
WE TALK ABOUT THE WOKENESS,
CHANGING OF STANDARDS.
DON'T GET VINDICTIVE.
DON'T GET NEGATIVE TOWARD THE
LATER, YOUNGER GENERATION RIGHT
NOW.
MENTOR FOLKS.
OUR COUNTRY INVESTED IN YOU,